la maestra de mariah es la encargada de
buscar algunos materiales en la bodega
de la escuela para hacer los adornos de
la ceremonia de fin de curso los
materiales que necesitas son papeles de
colores pegamento blanco plumones negros
flores de papel y listones de colores
conozcamos la bodega hay muchas cosas
para encontrar lo que necesita alguien
tendrá que ayudarle con indicaciones
claras para saber en dónde se encuentra
todo
el encargado de la bodega le dio la
siguiente lista papeles de colores
pegamento blanco plumones negros flores
de papel y listones
comencemos con los papeles de colores
que según la lista deben estar en la
tercera repisa del estante a la
izquierda de la puerta ok
tenemos tres estantes pero al que nos
interesa es el que está a la izquierda
de la puerta bien es este vamos a contar
las repisas 1 2 3 listo aquí están los
papeles
el pegamento blanco está en la segunda
repisa del estante a la derecha de la
puerta
es este una y dos repisas aquí está
sigamos con los plumones negros que
están dentro del tercer cajón del
escritorio que fácil sólo tenemos un
escritorio
entonces contemos 1 2 y 3 ya tenemos los
plumones ahora busquemos las flores de
papel la lista dice que se encuentran en
la tercera caja de la segunda repisa del
estante pequeño bueno el único estante
pequeño es el que está debajo de la
ventana pero hay cinco cajas localizamos
la correcta primera segunda tercera es
esta busquemos los listones de colores
para terminar se encuentran en el
interior de la caja grande que está
sobre el cilindro de colores que bien
sólo hay un cilindro y solo una caja
grande terminamos
las indicaciones claras con la ubicación
exacta nos ayudaron a no perder tanto
tiempo para buscar los materiales
además aplicamos nuestros conocimientos
para contar y nuestra habilidad para
seguir instrucciones e identificar
objetos